[Music]
homes in the box
I am due to a reason turn this enter I'm
looking wearing these little torn a sin
then enter from the back
[Music]
stay in the back end as I turn this
sensor it stayed in the back
do you put items in this don't do any
gymnastics just follow the rules that's
it that was a rule you took that step
try to survive
don't do anything just keep connected to
your own body
Turner Center center Center center turn
that's the drill go keep the rules
[Music]
okay so the noggin is going to move and
is gonna try not to fall okay but yeah
so I keep the rules it's a linear drop
keep my trip
it looks like you've been doing this
other stuff
it's just a leverage technique I'm not
doing that
watch the difference so when I take her
body I want you to think about her
structure so I go like this yup she's
tilted do you see that you see that but
look where her feet are now I'm gonna
throw her back what what happens okay
watch the other one okay so I'm not
going here
tiny inner not doing that I had to do it
on the air because she's always cowering
but I'm trying to enter senator go
forward through the center over the
center over the center no through the
center really Center st. in here you
could go easy but stronger people will
get it instead
overhead I'm not myself China this way
when they push they only push the Lyman
robbery further out so it's ruining the
center she pushes on me wish I'm gonna
push up on my arm up on my arm you see
it just takes our balance more so I'm
not going here
it's it is never acceptable intercessor
hold innocent go evil in her son in her
center this is where the leverage one is
and this is where the one I'm doing is
here's my life
you got never hand about hair I have a
red back here you get the head here by
moving the head I get that head down by
moving the legs here look don't do
anything you see
look either horizontal or head to her
feet on the other one
[Music]
this is the radius all doing this
leaving the center where it is and then
turning it around the center the center
hospital for center field center hasta
booth so forward progress forward
okay now put down
okay can you race with that foot I see
here if we're gonna put down but his
head's here the head in the foot plane
it's very close you see that brace
running you should not be getting that
[Music]
all of your here
you're not put your foot here that's
enough and should not work and you're
helping the delusion of the other person
okay so I would feel that we should so I
gotta get the foot or over here I
started doing that you can tell oh you
see that
so instead you should know he's too
tilted you see South to bring his centre
forward do you see like that okay now
let's test her to go back and his foot
starts to go down right just keep going
[Music]
okay let's go
this way has to move in order to keep
that direction she's going that way
[Music]
come on
okay that's unacceptable
this doesn't change for EDB not yet
either the more tilts here the bigger is
going to be the technique but if at the
beginning because you go too slow right
but if you do it at the beginning it's
very small but if you start the tilts
you would have do big movement okay but
either way it's not a matter of racing
it it's a matter of getting him people
wouldn't resist
you can't hide your deep work on people
who don't is this Hitler you can off the
power or people you're faster that
that's not what's the point of that you
could have ran away you were crossing
them right you're more powerful then you
don't need a technique all right
[Music]
keep pushing sango's right there and now
we have connection now it's winter
Center
[Music]
my foot in this one
that's your doing in the other two
techniques question okay so I'm not
doing this and I'm not doing that I go
right in there okay and then I work on
this
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel that to just be just be relaxed
and then in my training is throughout
all the way to the end
don't let him pull on me don't don't let
him so here